اولا جديد في تصريحات مكروم بعد طبعا
السماح بتسليم الدبابات الامريكيه
والالمانيه البريطانيه وايضا ربما
الفرنسيه اليوم الحديث عن طائرات مقاتله
ماذا يعني مكروه عندما يكون الامر ليس
مستبعدا للمبدا يعني ما قاله الفرنسي ردا
على السؤال حاول نقاش مثار منذ قرار تسليم
الدبابات الثقيله يثار في الاعلام بشكل
خاص وبناء طلب همم رئيس اوكراني حاول
طائرات مقاتله يقول من حيث من حيث المبدا
لا شيء مستبعده لا شيء ممنوعا ولكن معايير
ثلاثه يجب احترامها هي اولا ان تكون اي
مساعده عسكريه مفيده من حيث المهله وهمم
اللازمه لايصالها وتكون فعاله على الارض
ولا العامل الثاني لا تكون عامل تصعيدي في
الحرب ضد روسيا وفي مواجهه روسيا ونقطه
الثالثه لا تضعف الجيش الفرنسي بمعنى
تسليم اسلحه الجيش ليس بحوزته ما يكفي او
ما طبعا حاجته
ايضا في الدبابات عندما هناك تردد في
تسليم ضربات لوكلاغ لان جورج فرنسي لا
يملك الكثير منها مثال لجات اوكرانيا
لالمانيا الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ولبريطانيا بالتالي هل من الممكن اي تجاوب
باقي الحلفاء الغربيين مع طل اكياس خصوصا
في الطائرات المقاتله
قبل العام ما عندي لاعب الحرب حاولت
بولندا اقناع الولايات المتحده بالسماح
لها بتزويد كيف بطائرات الميجا 29 وانت
تستبدلها باف 16 والولايات المتحده وضعت
خطا احمر انا ذاك على هذا الامر اعتبرته
تصعيديا الان الامور بتتغير يعني هناك
تصريحات من داخل الولايات المتحده مستشار
الامن القومي يقول انها النقاش قائم حول
مساله تسليم المقاتلات ال- همم الامريكيه
ليس بالضروره مباشره انما السماح للدول
الاطلسيه وخاصه مثلا هولندا التي تملك هذه
الطائرات ان تقدمها لكيف وان تع الولايات
المتحده لهذه الدول بطائرات جديده او
بالطائرات اف 35 هناك نقاش قائم بهذا
الامر وهناك انقسام في الوقت نفسه المانيا
المستشار الالماني اغلق الباب نهائيا قال
هذا الامر لا يجب ان يطرح نهائيا على
الطاوله لانه يغير كل شيء في مساله الحرب
ونعرف انه اصلا بشان الدبابات كان متردده
فرنسا ذكرنا قبل الموقف رئيس فرنسي واضح
انه يعني مترددا في هذا الشان ويقول بانه
لا طلب رسميا ويجب دراسه هذا الامر وفي
القرار همم نتيجه بدرجه الاولى هو امريكي
قررت الولايات المتحده تجاوز هذه الخطوه
يمكن تاتي بعدها الناحيه العمليه هل هناك
همم مخزون كافر من الطائرات لاصاله الى
كيابل هذه الدول ويجب على المصنع الامريكي
تعويض هذه الدول معلومات الفناشر تهمس ان
المصنع الامريكيه 16 ابريل استعداده
لزياده الانتاج هل هذا يعبر عن همم بدا
سقوط محظور ك- او خط احمر جديد يعني كانت
حتى مش قد الدبابات ثقيله خطا احمر في
السابق احمر جديد لدى الدول الغربيه الدول
الاطلسيه في الدعم المقدم
لاوكرانيا واضح ان هناك امر جديد مطروح
على هذا الصعيد لكن يجب الحذر لان مساله
طائرات المقاتله تختلف كليا عن كل الاسلحه
التي قدمت السابقه
الاوكران على السير المعارك حتى على وجهها
هذه الحرب طبعا من ناحيه الميدانيه
العسكريه يعني من الصعب الاعتبار ان مجرد
وصول طائرات مقاتله الى اوكرانيا ستغير كل
مجرى الحرب وتعطي التفوق الجوي
للاوكرانيين ويسمح لهم ب- همم كسب الحرب
بسرعه لاسباب عند حسب القولون العسكريين
اولا ان هذه الطائرات همم طبعا يعتمد على
عددها وحجمها وكيف ستصل بحاجه لمهله طويله
للتاهيل الطيارين للتدريب الطيارين لايجاد
بالمؤتيه لها بما فيها الطائرات اوكس
المراقبه وغير ذلك حسب نوع الطائرات
وبالتالي بحاجه لوقت النقطه الثانيه هي من
يعرف رده فعل روسيا كيف ستكون وهل ستستطيع
الدول الغربيه كل يوم تذكر بانها ليست في
حرب مباشره ضد روسيا وليست حرب بين الاطلس
وروسيا ان ما تقوم به دعم اوكراني ان
تستمر بهذا الموقف وان روسيا لا تستغل هذا
الامر لتغير فعلا القواعد اللعبه لا شك ان
تسليم طائرات مقاتله في حال تم الخطوه هذه
الخطوه سيكون عامل مهم يغير من وجهه الحرب
لكن ليس بالضروره بسرعه ومن هنا ايضا نفهم
الحذر الكبير والحديث عن انها خطوه
تصعيديه كبيره من قبل خاصه المانيا
وفرنسا الامر الغير محسوم وان كنا شاهدنا
كثير من الخطوط الحمر التي سقطت خلال هذه
السنه وهذا خط احمر جديد نقاش حوله الان
لكن من الصعب القول بان والسيحسم سريعا
وحتى لو حسن انه سيغير رايكاليا مجرى
الحرب